you know I basically already written
this thing off long before now and then
[Music]
so the first trailer for solo Star Wars
story aired with the Super Bowl and
frustratingly it doesn't suck and I say
that and I want let me put my first
Asterix on there
I don't actively want the movie to suck
if it's going to exist I would prefer it
to be good however if the first trailer
flat-out sucked then it would be very
easy for me to just go oh okay there's
no hope but the trailer looked good and
that's infuriating because that means I
might now have expectations that I can
get disappointed on I didn't have
expectations of this movie before
which meant it could do nothing but
either meet low expectations or
pleasantly surprised me which is
basically what Justice League did now I
have some degree of expectations which
means it could fail to meet them and
disappoint me which was not the case
before I watched this trailer and yes
I'm actively annoyed that I enjoyed this
trailer God the world is weird right now
okay so the main thing driving my
enthusiasm for this initially honestly
it's the visuals this is a pretty
looking movie and like not just good
effects and like good composition
because I mean last Jedi had that too
let's be fair but also like there's some
invented visuals going on like that Star
Destroyer and the swirling hurricane
looking I don't know I don't know what
it was but it looked really cool and
this train that like bends as it goes
and there was this woman who was all
shiny and woody harrelson just looking
effortlessly cooled yet not quite right
which is it's his dangerous what he's
good at so when I say not quite right I
mean in an in an intriguing way and then
got Donald Glover just standing there
looking really cool and really suave and
and like so just visually right off the
bat oh my
that looks good that looks well-executed
that looks intriguing that looks
well-composed crap there's one thing in
this thing's favor and then I started to
I watched it a second time sort of
setting the visuals aside and get in
zeroing in my mind for what's the vibe
of this thing what's the feel of this
thing and it's a little different from
what we have gotten from Star Wars in a
while and I also like it damn it
okay so there's a much looser there's a
more free-flowing vibe to this and and
you know you get it even from the bits
of the impact like we get an empire
recruiter's like oh you want to sign it
up your god I love it
like that's not necessarily what you'd
expect from Star Wars but because it's
in the proper Star Wars trapping you
kind of stop and think huh if they did
have recruiters didn't they yeah I mean
because they had the oh the
stormtroopers they'd clothes for The
Groundlings but I mean they needed
technicians they needed pilots they
needed to go out and recruit they would
have had basically a pitchman yeah that
makes sense yeah I kind of want to see
this ridiculous
you know recruitment angle for for the
Empire not like I expect that to be a
big chunk of the movie but like that's
where I started to zero in on the vibe
of the thing and it's it's it's a
Cantina vibe it is a New Hope Cantina
vibe of yeah you know there's all kinds
of stuff going on but you know we're
just kind of having a good time it's
just relaxed it's like oh weird aliens
over there don't mind the guy who just
shot somebody over in the booth like I
in like 40 friggin seconds and like a
handful of wines and a distinctly
different visual approach from that
scene and a new hope I still got that
vibe and that is the perfect vibe if
you're going to do a han Solo movie
which again I will stress and I will
continue to stress is a bad idea however
I will now have to follow that up with
the fact that bad ideas can make good
movies the lego movie was a bad idea
and actually having now gotten a sense
of the vibe of this film I see why Lord
and Miller the guys behind the lego
movie were originally put on to it
because if they're going for that kind
of fun vibe they would have been a good
fit for that it's just that their
approach and their looseness in terms of
sticking to the script is obviously what
didn't work for you know for the folks
at Lucasfilm but I don't want to rehash
all that so moving out from that if yeah
okay look let me say there's I literally
have no problems with this trailer in
and of itself
I really don't I watched it like four
times I also should point out it didn't
get I never got the tingles down the
spine I never got the chill down the
spine that I got from the trailers for
rogue one for the force awakens for the
last Jedi I need with specific trailers
in every case it wasn't like every
trailer gave me that
but you each of them had one trailer
that gave me that chill this does not do
it but it's still good and like I look
like I have nothing to complain about it
looks good I like the vibe I like the
feel from what little I can glean from
it if I'm gonna put on my you know not
ignoring my designation of honorary
buzzkill so let's let's put that hat on
for a second the cynic in me would point
to the fact that we only hear Han Solo
speak once and we only see his face once
my cynical mind says they're hiding him
cuz he is not very good in the part
however I have a rebuttal from my own
cynical argument which is right now the
word of mouth on solo specifically for
its production history and honestly Star
Wars in general right now is mixed to
highly skeptical depending on who you
talk to and it is a much smarter
approach rather than to go here's solo
he looks like solo don't you buy a solo
to put him aside basically bench him and
focus on giving a feel for the film
overall giving a feel for how they're
approaching Star Wars how they're
approaching the world getting giving a
feel for the vibe of the film which is
what I zeroed in on what I liked so
while it is possible that they are
hiding him because he sucks it could
also be that this is really really
really smart marketing and they need to
remind people that Star Wars can be good
and light and fun and doesn't have to
deconstruct itself and depress the heck
out of half its fandom and then worry
about inserting and selling us on this
guy as solo a little bit later because
honestly that's the harder sell because
we all know Hera we all know and love
Harrison Ford so it if it if there if
it's not because they're hiding him then
this is a really smart marketing move
because they're selling a vibe they're
selling a tone they're selling a look
and that right now is an easier sell and
it's a good idea to try and get on fans
good size before you try and sell the
much harder thing which is somebody else
playing han Solo and as somebody who did
not like the last Jedi and as somebody
who kind of didn't really want to talk
about Star Wars for Ohio huh I liked the
trailer damn it Disney like white why
can't you just hit a consistent level
suck with this so you can stop yanking
my expectations up and down I could I
could safely I could walk it away and
walk away from it and be fine with that
but now I can't because I've seen the
trailer my crap that looks good so those
were my very weird and jumbled and
conflicted thoughts of liking but not
wanting to like the trailer for solo
Star Wars story I really do hope I eat
my words for all the times I said that
I'm sure this is gonna suck that will be
nice I enjoyed eating my words on Wonder
Woman on that same basis so we'll see
what happens but the Superbowl ad for so
star wars movie how much you want to bet
they release a fuller version of that
trailer the same day I put this video
out which will make it immediately
outdated hopefully if I'm lucky it's
just like another 30 seconds or
something and he added to it it's not
some substantively different but that's
just my luck in any case have you seen
that's the Super Bowl spots whatever you
thought about it drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it do all
the stuff you know support like
subscribe patreon Twitter whatever you
want to do I got links for all my other
stuff down in the description so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]